great pleasure to be here at sells to
society symposium honoring Clyde my own
career has been a bit of a sells to
society journey myself I actually
started off as a as a medical student
doing work on the development of the
midbrain doing the rimoni qahal draw
drawings of cells and working with a guy
named Paschal rockies on looking at how
the midbrain developed and went on into
the pediatrics and as tomboys knows
moved to Oakland Children's Hospital
where I ran something called the center
for the vulnerable child looking at
children in foster care and it was
through that process that I remember
going to Tom with Bruce McEwan's article
in Scientific American about
psychoneuroimmunology and sort of saying
you know these kids in foster care have
very weird biologically aberrant
trajectories that have to do what's
going on and the stuff that McEwan's
writing about makes a lot a lot of sense
and I found myself putting band-aids on
the boo-boos of kids in foster care we
got very good at taking care of them and
doing the kind of infant mental health
kinds of assessments and interventions
but I realized there weren't enough
band-aids and enough people like myself
to put band-aids that we had to move
upstream and I continued to move
upstream and upstream until I found my
way to Clyde and I did that partially
through two mentors of mine one was Phil
Lee was at kind of the Fraser Mustard of
the US and the other was through lens
side and both of them said you got to go
meet this guy Clyde herzman and Len said
and people that know Len Len doesn't
dish out faint praise Len says you're
going to meet a few geniuses in your
life and he'll be one of them and I it
was it was actually 10 years later that
I actually met Clyde and I was at a
pediatric academic Society meeting in
Seattle and my friend Barry Zuckerman
who was doing reach out and read across
the United States and the other friend
Franco Burke laid we rented a car
Seattle and drove to Vancouver to meet
to meet Clyde it was like you know our
sort of Lord of the Ring journey quest
you know where it might been more like
the Disney three copy arrows but we
headed across the border to meet the
wizard you know and and there he was and
he took us in and walked us around the
park and and and showed us what he did
and we were all odd and and for the next
12 years I worked with Clyde in in
various ways and one of the ways I think
about Clyde is that he was really like a
virtuoso musician and his instrument was
his brain it was his mind his ability
actually to play with lots of people in
many city set settings and to really do
riffs on what you would put something
out and he would just take it you know
it was like the Yo Yo Ma of human
development in my mind and I the other
thing that I also just really
appreciated about him was his ability
you know with social gradients to talk
about the gratings and to recognize how
important the concept was in terms of
democratizing risk so that you weren't
talking about the poor children but you
were looking at how all of us were on
the gradient list the the slope of the
gradient put us all together in a way
that it changed the political discussion
so I I feel like I owe a great deal of
both gratitude and debt to Clyde and
also for his integrity not meaning his
honesty but his integrity and the way
that he continued to unflagging Lee sort
of pursue the goal of equity and issues
of promoting children's welfare and as
opposed to many who I know that have a
patina of outrage his outrage was deep
in terms of what motivated him and he
took a lot of risks and that's you know
I think also what defined his integrity
he wasn't always subject to the tyranny
of the p value or the tyranny of other
kinds of things that often motive like
many of us to lose I think our way and I
think that was a great inspiration for
me so
I'm gonna really rapidly go through talk
about how the health system needs to be
changed and the opportunity for children
to lead the way I'm going to talk a bit
about the health development of children
a little bit about life course
development which I think that in the
health field that Clyde is added greatly
to and I'm going to talk about this 3.0
transformation framework that we're
using in the United States now and I'm
going to if I get time I'll talk about
how using complex system science and
communities can actually be used to
change things so we need to be
transforming our system our health is
improving but we have very low
performing health and health care
systems with low quality high cost and
poor outcomes and that for sure in the
US I think it's the same case in Canada
and the UK although their costs are
quite different
we have great inequalities of Health and
they're growing and that we have graphic
rapidly growing knowledge that we're not
translating and though we've all seen
these kinds of curves and what you see
on the United States at the top is the
picture of an enormous Lea inefficient
healthcare system the cost more and has
the worst outcomes in fact there was a
recent IOM report on this why the u.s.
is the sickest of rich nations and part
of that has to do with the fact that in
that in the United States as is in most
of the world that we're seeing these
increasing curves as the number of
people with chronic diseases is growing
up at a very rapid rate I need to
realize the u.s. health economy is going
to spend 2.7 trillion dollars it you
know we're talking about huge sums of
money bigger than most the economies and
though in the world on health care but
it's being driven by this increase in
chronic disease that it's happening and
we know that there are various things
happening to children in terms of
chronic disease and we know that the
obesity epidemic is one of them but when
we actually look at what's going on in
children what we see is their increased
chronic health problems with 16 to 30%
of children the United States having
chronic health problems at the president
it's not haemophilia cancer congenital
heart disease what it is is the growing
prevalence of mental health
conditions with 22% of children or
adolescents have mental health
conditions with impairments a greater
appreciation for the role of
neurodevelopmental disorders also very
common and lots of kids with
comorbidities and what we need to
recognize is ADHD as men obesity are
increasing but they're actually related
you know why they're going up they're
not separate diseases and for the mental
health I think is going to be in the
next obesity what we're seeing is a
rapidly increase in mental health and
what we know about it is developmentally
it's all happening between ages 10 and
24 the cumulative prevalence of mental
health disorders goes up incredibly
during that time period with great cost
and even though as people interested in
health about and we talk about
adolescence as a sensitive period of
development it's actually a critical
period for the health care system
because we're accumulating so much risk
that will play through for the rest of
the life course I'll come to that we're
also seeing the United States that the
disability rates for children are going
up so in 1960 we had 2% of children that
were classified as disabled now it's 8%
and the face of disability has changed
so in 1960 that it's able child was a
little girl with with crutches and
braces on her leg who had polio the pit
the poster child for disability now is a
child with autism and so we've seen this
massive change that's going on and so
what we know when looking at the
epidemiology is that 48% of kids have
severe disabilities we have 12 to 16
percent of kids that are classified in
the US as having special health care
needs by our maternal child health
Bureau and eligible for different kinds
of services but we have somewhere
between 20 and 40% of kids that have
behavioral neural and developmental
learning problems and then we have about
50 to 60% of kids that are good enough
you know and I put good enough you're
laughing a bit because how many people
here have kids and you know most of you
and you don't look at your own kids and
say oh you're good enough unless you
have a teenager and we don't manage
towards good enough we're managed
towards optimum health and we want to
know what percentage of our children are
thriving but when you look at this and
when you start to realize that you have
40% of the children that are carrying a
burden of morbidity
that they're going to carry forward in
their lives it's a daunting task and
it's not about making incremental
changes anymore it's not even it's about
making transformation the basic
structures and how we're doing what
we're doing so and what we know across
the net across the world from the UNICEF
report that came out this is the 2013
version the United States is right at
the bottom
Canada is right there in the UK's right
above it but we're all on the bottom
half of the distribution and there's a
reason for that and part of it has to do
with our legacy of the Elizabethan Poor
Laws and how we built those into our
social structure but that's another
story this is not quite as fast a thing
isn't it
we also know that economic adversity
affects child outcomes kids are born
early we know that they have worse
physical cognitive emotional health
they're hospitalized more with more
mental health problems lower health
trajectories they carry this burden of
their social status into adulthood and
we know more about how it's programmed
into their biology thanks to Clyde and
others in this room have been doing the
research we also know that when young
children fall behind everybody pays that
in terms of school failure in terms of
social relationships and the ability to
form families in terms of long-term
costs and social dependency in terms of
decreased productivity and lifelong
health problems these are the quote
quote externalities that we're dealing
with in terms of from a social
standpoint and what we know is also that
these differences start early this is
the famous hard Risley studies that
everybody's now looking at even though
they've been around for the last 20
years there's a big thing now in the
United States about the 30 million word
gap the White House has been doing 30
million word gap and we actually thought
the president was going to talk about
the 30 million word gap because it's so
hot right now but but what this is
showing is that basically by you know 16
months or whatever you start to see this
playing and these trajectories and you
see these big differences that are
developing then our compound over time a
recent study in close one that came out
last month from the brain scan study
that was done on young children
basically showed in looking at total
gray matter over the
verse 36 and months of age you see the
function and structure are related and
you see that the brain scan and they
actually total gray matters the same
thing that you're seeing in the heart
and Ridgeley studies and the issue here
is not that you know you have these kids
on the lower trajectory with lower brain
mass and lower functional status but
when you look in the United States we
have 48% of our young children below the
low income threshold for having that
sort of resources that they need to
thrive so this isn't about a safety net
that we have to create we have to
rebuild the bridges and the scaffolding
for human development it's a hold it's a
very different kind of issue and as we
know looking at our kids entering
kindergarten we have these huge social
gradients and this is from our early
childhood longitudinal birth cohort
study and you see these huge social
gradients and we have to start figuring
out again courtesy of Clyde how do we
start shifting the curve now how do we
bring up the tail of the curve but how
do we shift the whole curve and really
where's the leverage point where are we
going to have the maximum leverage to
actually change things so from Clyde we
know also from this I stole this from
him and again as a musician sort of riff
on it you know we know these things
domino through the life course we know
that when children don't do well early
on you see all these problems that take
place you know in the first second
second third fourth and into old age and
I remember Clyde talking about how
Alzheimer's disease is a disease of
early childhood in in essence that these
things are all connected and so we have
the situation in which we have an ideal
trajectory for children our current
practice gets as far lower than we
should be and we have this enormous
missed opportunity
so where does this leave us well
conceptually where it leaves us is
there's been a lot of progress for us to
rethink what we're doing and not again
I'm talking as a physician and someone
who works in the medical world and looks
at that 2.7 trillion dollars that's
being spent and the wrong time in the
wrong place and I start to think about
however how is our thinking changed
and we we've gone through several eras
of healthcare but what we started with
was this sort of biomechanical model
that was formed out of germ theory 1800s
you know the Anna Anna anatomical and
pathological models and it basically was
a simple mechanistic linear view of what
disease was about and unfortunately most
of our medical schools are still largely
stuck there and we know because of
Framingham and the Alameda County
studying the kind of work that Michael
Marmot and when Syme and others did and
the kind of behavioral work that was
done that we moved towards this
biopsychosocial Maya model and by the
1970s and this is a hierarchical dynamic
systems model that looks at multiple
determinants in a different way but
what's happened in the last 15 years
through the lifespan chronic disease
epidemiology the the epigenetics
neurodevelopment work what we've seen
now is a new model that's developing
around life course health development
and this is actually an important
paradigm and frame shift that's
happening and it's this up models
complex relational dynamic and
developmental so it's function it's in
we have to think and it it guides our
science in a different way
and what I think is happening when you'd
sort of connect this to what's happening
on the basic science side and you see
the same kind of changes that have gone
on that what we're actually moving
towards is this new integrated model of
health development that's going to guide
our science and going to begin to bring
public health and medicine together and
begin to really reframe how we think
about health and healthcare as we move
forward and what's interesting about
this and part of why I put this out as
this is coming together you're starting
to see work on the genome and gene
networks and looking at you know
Waddington topography or
epigenetic landscape and I think part of
why Clyde was so taken with mapping the
social jeanette a social genome or
looking at social epigenetics is that he
really understood deeply how the
landscape of people's lives in the
landscape of the epigenetic process were
actually linked and was interested in
sort of making those connections again
so from the life course health
development what we're seeing and this
comes out of a working group at NIH on
the health science life course Health
Sciences group that's working on health
measurement the principles we've been
we've been coming up with is that health
is an emergent property of living
systems that health develops
continuously over the lifespan that
health development is complex nonlinear
process the results from person
environmental interactions that are
multi-dimensional multi-directional
multi-level that health development is
highly sensitive to the timing and
social structuring of experience and
environmental exposures and this is what
Clyde and Tom and everybody was working
on that evolution enables and constrains
health development path pathways and
plasticity in all kinds of important
ways that optimal health development
promotes survival enhances thriving and
protects against disease and that the
cadence of human health development
results from this synchronization and
timing and molecular physiological
culture and evolutionary processes that
the timing issues end up being very very
important the clocks and the cells and
the clocks in our lives are all
connected and so that we have these
time-sensitive pathways again from Clyde
you know that understands that toxic
stress affects the epigenome is
affecting things in time-sensitive ways
we know that there are these
trajectories of brain development
looking at glucose metabolism and
synaptic density and we understand
whether the periods of rapid growth are
and we understand now in very simplified
terms because we have to be able to take
this to policymakers and Boards of
Education and other people so that they
can understand this that kids can go
into a delayed or disordered trajectory
or in an at-risk trajectory and as I was
talking about we have probably 40 or 50
percent of our kids in these at-risk
trajectories and it has to do with
poverty lack of health services and
toxic stress and if you're going to go
on a higher trajectory you need more
protective factors so from a very
simplified way is what public policies
about is how do we how do we decrease
the number of risk factors and make sure
that they don't have the impact that
there
increase the number of protective
factors in children's lives and it's not
just individual perpective protective
factors but how do we build the social
scaffolding that actually makes that
part of what our society does for our
children so how's the science informing
policy as we move forward and how do we
translate this in the medical world
which is still largely biomedically
focus well there's another story to be
told and this is this 3.0 transformation
framework and this comes from Lester
Breslow who talked about how there were
three areas of healthcare and three
major transitions the first era was
focused on saving lives through acute
care emergency and rescue care and
public health safety the second era
focused largely on prolonging life in
decreasing levels of disability through
chronic disease management and that's
where we're at now and the third era
works were emerging into will focus on
optimizing health and well-being through
more primary prevention health promotion
and community integrated delivery
systems so it looks something like this
from the 1850s or 1700s depending on
where you want to put it you know life
expectancy in 1900 was about 47 years
that focused on infectious disease the
chip in the system the operating logic
was the biomedical logic we use short
timeframes because everything was acute
and medical we developed our medical
care model our hospitals and clinics
developed during this first era we
develop our insurance based financing
mechanism again because we're they were
shirring against the unexpected and we
used a basically an industrial model of
production that's why most of our
hospitals look like factories in terms
of how they're organized and the focus
was on reducing death when we go through
the great epidemiologic transition that
happens in the early part of the last
century we go from life expectancies of
about 47 years to 68 years by the 1950s
and we entered the chronic disease era
and there's an increased focus on
chronic disease we now spend 75% of our
health care dollars on chronic disease
in our country and years and the model
shifts to the biopsychosocial model
because of Framingham and others and we
start to understand that these chronic
diseases like heart disease are caused
by
Yee what you do the kind of environments
you live in and so time frames have to
increase because we're not managing
short-term we're managing now over
months years and decades and we move to
a different kind of framework and our
healthcare benefits change as well it's
no longer insurance but we're paying in
advance for the colonoscopies and the
cholesterol screaming and all the rest
of what we knew and we're moving towards
more corporate models of health care to
organize healthcare and these corporate
entities in the United States we have
something called Kaiser we're gonna see
these accountable care organizations are
forming two org and I see have better
vertical integration of the production
model and the focus is on prolonging
disability for your life we're headed
towards this third era where it's it's
going to increasingly focus on optimal
health development because we now have
most of the seventy year olds when you
ask them about their health status about
60 to 70% of them will say it's
excellent very good so we've gotten to a
place in life in our history that we can
produce optimal health and the model is
now changing towards this lifecourse
health development model this is going
to be the new chip that's going to drive
the health system forward and it's going
to focus on lifespan and generational
kinds of issues so what we talked about
the epigenetic research that looking
across generations this is what it's
going to inform and we're going to move
more towards network models of delivery
of care and networks in communities in
terms of how they'll be organized so
it's moving from this 1.0 system to this
2.0 system to the 3.0 system the u.s.
health system is about 1.8 canada might
be at 1.9 most of the european systems
are about 2.2 in terms of what they're
doing
and well just to go back to this model
what we see is that basically we're
moving from the first era to the second
era to the third era so this is how
science informs policy that informs the
way that we're moving forward so just
how do we connect cells to society in a
way that actually has a functional
policy model that we can make actionable
and the reason it ends up being
important is back to our trajectories if
you go into a low health trajectory or
high health trajectory we know most of
the action is happening early on so
that's the pivot point all right that's
where you're going to get the change in
the trajectories in line and we know
when you go into an early or low health
trajectory by 55 you're obese you have
diabetes you have heart disease and
you're depressed and that's and that's
what your healthcare cost curve looks
like and that's where we're spending our
money if you went into a higher health
trajectory and you spent more early on
we would have a very different looking
cost curve and the importance here is in
the United States we're spending all of
our time on the entire rallying cry of
our health reform is how do we bend the
cost curve how do we actually squeeze it
down a little bit in the end which is a
it's a fool's errand you're never gonna
squeeze the cost curve very much at the
end of life well we really need to be
thinking about is how we move from 1.0
models and even the 2.0 models that are
trying to work on chronic disease and
prevent to how we move upstream not just
to the upstream social determinants but
to the developmental determine of how
towards 3.0 models because that's where
we have the leverage so we should be
talking about how do we shift the health
curve in order to shift the cost curve
rather than thinking that will bend the
cost curve and this is taking hold of us
our Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
innovation as a adopt at this 3.0
framework and they're using it now for
state innovation models in order to
think about what is a 3.0 design of a
health system look like what a community
accountable health systems working on
population health start to look like as
opposed to where we're at and this
episodic 9 integrated care that we
currently have and how do we move
forward how do you design and move
forward over a longer time horizon and
what are the social and political and
other forces law of that to happen so
what we've been doing and I'm going to
try to go through the last third of my
presentation in the next 30 seconds is
that we have a transformation framework
so how do you start transforming the
system and I'm not going to go through
all of these
I don't have time but one way you start
transforming is change the logic so we
go from a logic of your new operating
system where you're developing
capacities and realizing potential of
the individuals you're optimizing the
health of a population you're dealing
with the individual population the
community it's a different kind of
operating logic for what you actually
build your system around and that's what
Clyde was interested in okay Clyde was
interested in health trajectories he was
interested in how you start connecting
things up and he used the EDI as an
anchor point for that so the ADI allowed
him to look at school readiness which is
health develop health-related quality of
life of a five-year-old if you're in the
health care world right it's a health
development measure and what the EDI
does as a measures children and it looks
at all these domains in children in a
comprehensive way and that you can look
at and be done in 10 min and 10 minutes
or 12 minutes and you can get a census
on kids in kindergarten and you all know
about it but when I saw this for the
first time in 2002 when Magdalena Janus
and Dan offered brought these maps to LA
for a meeting that we had of the four
countries England the UK and the US and
Canada for me it was like seeing one of
these for the first time you know I went
gosh where did you get that I want one
of those because you could see it was a
game-changer you know what you know
completely changed what you would do I
remember calling Michael Marmot a
several years ago and I asked Michael
you keep talking about social
inequalities how the heck do you measure
and he said you know this guy Clyde
herdsman he says he's got the best I
said yeah do I know you no but but we
tried for about ten years to bring this
to the United States the our friends in
Australia Franco Burke late who was at
the same meeting only a few years later
took it back to the Australia Australia
right now does the EDI on the entire
country alt all 290,000 kindergarten
kids and every single county every
places is measured in the important part
about this again a thing that I learned
from Clyde is what Clyde was doing the
not dealing in data what Clyde was doing
is taking data and turning it into
information right and information is the
difference that makes the difference
Clyde was all about what makes a
difference and it's taking that inferred
and turning them for information as
Gregory Bateson said it's about the
difference that makes a difference
but Clyde went went one step further and
he said how do we take that information
and turn it into currency how do we make
it so valuable that those maps those EDI
maps are like 20 or 50 dollar bills that
become valuable in a public policy
sphere that become valuable to a
community because it tells them
something about themselves and they can
trade upon it and use it and that's part
of how we need to be thinking how do we
create new markets of social value that
we can actually exchange and use and it
may take our data as researchers not
just as data that give us little micro
information but the kind of macro
information that we need to make big
kinds of changes so this is what we're
doing in California and Orange County I
won't go into this because you know I'm
in the land of EDI so but it's just to
show you that we're wannabes and we're
moving this forward beauty of the EDI
also is that it's great at measuring the
social gradients that's what Michael was
telling me if you want to measure social
gradient you're not gonna find anything
better and this is what we're doing now
in the United States we have 40 sites
across the United States that are
measuring the EDI and we're doing in all
kinds of places from you know New
Orleans and Detroit and various places
and it's all being used for different
reasons and what we're doing is we're
trying to figure out how do we use this
to actually make change what do we do to
make change and so in any community you
go into you're gonna find lots of
programs that have exists already
because we have a whole legacy of
creating child care and mental health
services preschools and stuff and if
you're a low-income parent right and you
have both a Social Work degree and a
degree in civil engineering you're
golden right because with those two
degrees you'll be able to find all these
things because you know that's that's
the only way because they weren't
designed to be user-friendly
right but what we've learned over time
is it's not about the services it's
about the systems and that we have to
embrace the complexity of the problem
we're doing it dealing with its human
development and Community Development
are complex problems they're not simple
problems and they they don't respond to
mechanical solutions we need to scale
the change that's needed and these be
complex problems have to work at scale
you have to be thinking about working at
scale now and 150 kids in a little place
and think that that's going to give you
the answer and cut and the most
important thing that I think I've
learned from the complex systems work is
that complex systems learn their way
forward so you have to have a learning
system that turns the data in different
information and currents and if you're
not doing that you're not going to
progress and so the person from
education and health social welfare have
to come together they have to all be
able to learn from each other take it
back and continuously learn in a
virtuous cycle that moves you forward
and you have to have data at the right
level that you're working at you can't
use infant mortality or some other data
and a community health center because
it's not it's not scaled right and we
haven't quite figured that out either so
if we're going to move things forward
we're using this model from again from
complexity theory and any community you
have lots of individual programs doctors
and nutrition programs and early
childhood breeding programs and they're
all trying to provide human development
you have complex levels of organizations
and the aid agencies at a community
level and then you have the county and
city governments but what this looks
like you have funding streams that
connected all the silos that we know
that exist and they actually make the
program's work the way the program's
work but this is like a big weather
pattern and you know looking at Bruce's
allostatic load complexity model that's
what the community looks like that's why
people's Allis static loads are going up
because they're living in this complex
world where everything is like a pinball
machine you know and so what what we
have is this weather pattern that's
close to chaos
and the question is if we're going to
move forward we have to get alignment at
the governmental levels you and that's
what happened with SureStart in England
when Blair and bran moved in and and
Gordon Brown came in and the Secretary's
or the commissioners or whatever they're
called of Education held early childhood
we're all sitting there like this and
said we're not you know gonna give you
our money or do anything and Gordon
Brown said I'm the Treasury and you're
gonna do what I say and they got a line
that's one way of aligned but we have to
figure out how we align things how do
you get community-based organizations
hospitals clinics different kinds of
places serving children how do they work
as a network and if we can do that we
can get alignment we can get actually
pathways that work for people if in fact
we want pathways for development of
scaffolding we have to build it and
design it make it work that way so you
need a learning system to make that
happen and so we've been figuring out
how do you build a learning system how
do you take all these programs how do
you align early childhood education
health family support how do you develop
a common agenda and communicate about it
how do you have shared outcomes and
accountability so I'm accountable to the
help to the education person that we're
all accountable to each other how do you
have a collaborative system improvement
so you're all working together on the
same kind of improvement system the way
that Toyota or any big corporation now
works the way they learn their way
forward is they use a common system of
learning the way our universities have a
common culture of learning so how do you
create a common cultural learning in a
community and how do you align the
finances and policy so I'm over but let
me just tell you quickly about Magnolia
place you've heard a lot about the
Harlem Children's Zone in the United
States anything everything it takes or
whatever it takes to make things work
you know and thirty or forty million
dollars of hedge fund money and you can
get things to move Magnolia is a
different kind of entity in Los Angeles
an Oregon a group of people came
together and said rather than building a
place that will take care of 400 or 500
kids in a Bowtique Educare or some
kind of place where we're going to
provide everything in one place how do
we work at scale with 35,000 kids and
how do we make them thrive and so
there's six hubs in the Magnolia area
it's it's a five square mile part of Los
Angeles about a hundred thousand people
300,000 35,000 kids
there's seventy-one partner
organizations working together there's a
hundred community groups five hundred
block advocates that are being developed
and fourteen thousand families and here
are the EDI maps for the area so we're
measuring EDI and green but what you're
seeing is the revolt vulnerability
around communication on one of the EDI
skills and when they you're mapping how
often are parents reading to their kids
so we now have at a neighborhood level
the outcome and the inputs in terms of
what's going on and it allows for a very
different kind of discussion that takes
place so we're taking these results out
to the community and the community is
actually working together and managing
towards it and this is the kind of thing
that Clyde was moving forward in in
various communities in British Columbia
but what we've been doing is developing
a whole set of instruments and tools to
move this forward so that we can take
collective action so how do you take
collective action how do you leverage
this forward and this is just a bunch of
community groups coming together and
working on problems and doing what we
are cycles a plan do study act they're
trying to improve things as they move
forward so back to our model part of
what we're trying to do is develop a
learning system so we're developing
mechanisms and ways of aligning things
integrating the network so that we can
learn creating using the analytics and
data so that we can turn it into
currency and figuring out how we can
have adaptive flexible high-performing
service pathways how do we actually
construct that to move forward so - and
Clyde was all about promoting equity
from the start promoting ik early child
development is about achieving greater
social
uh quitting their early years provide an
opportunity to invest in early childhood
development and we believe that this
life course health development model
that you can bring in the health sphere
to restructure the to seven two point
seven trillion dollars in a different
way is a way for us to begin to think
big about how you get the leverage that
the conventional wisdom and current
knowledge or at nah I had odds in terms
of what we need to do that disparities
that begin early in life continue to
tilt forward and compound over time that
this 3.0 integrated framework starts to
integrate time life course context and
actors and agents in a way because
that's what we're doing the research on
but we have to figure out how do we
integrate this in a complex system that
we need to figure out how we leverage
the arc of human development we so we
can optimize things and we need to be
really thinking about what the design
principles and the leverage points and
where we make things move so that we can
make the economic and human cost of not
transforming our systems the enormous
disaster that they are and move it in
different directions thanks very much
you